thanks for joining us at 11 I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis Nathan
chasing horse previously banned from
multiple places the eight news now
investigators learning the Dances with
Wolves actor was not only banished from
a Native American reservation here in
the U.S but it also happened more than
once in Canada so how did the accused
child rapists go under the radar for so
long it's what eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy is trying to
get to the bottom
yeah Nathan chasing horse is now wanted
in Canada Federal authorities they're
issuing a warrant for sexual assault
after another woman came forward and the
satina police in Canada also saying more
charges are on the way Las Vegas Metro
Police say the alleged cult leader
victimized indigenous women and children
for at least two decades sources tell us
they believe alleged victims were
ignored we asked about this at this
virtual press conference if you feel as
though you were ignored on any sexual
assault investigation
um
that you need to come forward and we are
committed to make sure that your voice
is heard
we don't want our victims to be further
victimized by being ignored chasing
horse faces charges in Clark County
after his arrest in North Las Vegas on
January 31st on Monday a courtroom tents
as alleged victims and supporters of
chasing horse showed up we tried
speaking with his father what do you
want to say about the allegations
against him we've learned the FBI is
investigating Nathan chasing horse
multiple sources tell me it's about time
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now